[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined by Martin garrix he's always
travelling he's always touring he's got
a single in the name of love that's
burning up the charts right now just
performed it on Fallon I understand
right yeah we just got here from from
home and then you walk across the street
over to this Wayne's World operation
quite the fall from grace yeah I'm happy
to be here you are him at least Jesus
nervous to be here then I was there
phone because of all these sauces and
we've been trying to work it out for a
while finally we got you Martin I'm so
happy to hear how are you with hot food
not good well I'll do my best
all right you ready to get going let's
do it
[Music]
so the first one is sriracha so growing
up in the Netherlands I know that used
to play your parents friends weddings
and that's sort of how you got your
start but I have to imagine that there's
something about those humble beginnings
that you miss I miss anything no no for
me every show is different you know I
love playing festival shows but I also
really love very small intimate club
shows where you it's easier to connect
with the people of course weddings it's
not really do you said.you mainly just
background music but there was also fun
like I would be like doing music and
then someone would come up with like a
CD I can't can't please play this and if
it happened right now I would freak out
but and it's very it was very funny and
I learned a lot from it as well you take
small bites Marky I'm gonna regret this
Martin I'll remember you said that I'll
remember you said that this is a free
throw your big bite Martin if you want
to just alright so I know that you love
pizza and there's a whole corner of the
internet that's sort of dedicated to
Martin's love for pizza
where's the best pizza in the world I've
had the best pizza in my life and apples
in Italy yeah it is Italy is that for me
it's it's an incident and we went there
to a super local place and we met like
the the chef and it was with like
mozzarella and mushrooms it was amazing
I love pizza
[Music]
so watch this big-ass bite I'm about to
take
I feel like
so I know that you went to the Hermann
brew Academy for those who don't know
it's kind of a trade school for music
production right it's kinda like a DJ
college it's cool because when I went to
high school I was this weird dude like
making me I just hope he we should not
really love people ahead then I went to
the Herman broad Academy and everybody
had the same passion at the same love
for music and the same love for
producing so instead of talking about
football or something during the school
breaks we would talk about new plugins
and like nerd stuff and for me it was it
was super much fun and it must have been
a strange time in your life if what I
understand is true did animals come out
when you were in your first year yeah
yeah for me that was a really insane I
made animals at the end of the first
year and I started touring and or like
getting show requests I'm not doing full
tours but I would I would like play
shows on Friday Saturday Sunday and
Sunday night after show fly back to be
in school on Monday was it hard to take
your professors seriously because I
think it would be for me if that
happened to me I'd be a cautionary tale
I'd be such a nightmare to all my
teachers cuz I'd be like no one can tell
me anything it was weird for everyone
including me but for me I went to the
school to learn more it was really
really helpful and I don't think I was
such a bigot pain is good I think again
a style phrase for this picture picture
tells the story of the sauce paint is
good
embrace it no one in the world I think
travels better than you whether it's
yacht life or it's the private jet
situation but every once in a while
you'll end up on a floor at Miami
International and have to fly commercial
but the farm animals like me but I have
to know what's the best mode of
transportation in your opinion is that
the helicopter is that the yacht is the
PJ with the situation I love bikes bikes
yeah I'm from Eminem everybody likes
bikes there and I used to always drive
my bike to school you're just very
portable so I I would go for a bike is
the Wi-Fi good on private jets are not
so good as its body it's it's there's
not even Wi-Fi all the Jets wow wow I
sound like so just boiled right
no but it's no it's not it's true it's
true when you live life when you live
life these are things that you
experience these are things that people
are curious about we have to apologize
for that
Plus that's a good point like everybody
thinks I call private abba-baba-baba not
even good Wi-Fi maybe you are better off
you probably have the best Instagram of
anyone that we've ever had on the show
we like to do deep dives on instagrams
cool find some pictures that we think
are interesting that need more contact
you heard me the story behind the
picture that sounds good all right you
have a lot of pictures like this but I
need to point it out because the energy
looks so crazy the pyrotechnics do these
all sort of blend together or do you
remember this moment can look it up
close yeah I yeah isn't it crazy oh you
can create a spectacle like this I think
this because it happens every night they
all kind of blend I think this this was
Japan no I think I do like 150 shows a
year it's a cool part from the show like
I do the music and stuff but there's so
much more going on there's like as
effects like the pyro fireworks co2 and
you've like lights lasers visuals it's
it's a it's really really fun building
building a show it's never distracting
for you it gets very distracting when it
gets launched at the wrong time I wasn't
in Russia recently and it was not
someone from my team cueing it and I was
beautiful moans girls guys like it was a
like super pretty chill and his son of
the others like this one you and Bill
need to know what's going on with you
and Bill Clinton here I met him in Vegas
he invited me first foundation to play
poker with him and then as soon as I
arrived there they ID'd me and I'm I'm
20 so I wasn't allowed in the casino now
this is something that you do every once
in a while where you'll be in this sort
of opulent grand setting and then you'll
just be sitting there by yourself like
you'll be on stage you're surrounded
with so many people but then when you
get to the hotel room you're you're by
yourself you know and this was I think
one year ago
it was such a such a big table and they
set up the entire table because I
expected me to be there with so many so
I was like I'm just gonna sit down you
ready to move on to a second I just
really put like the hot sauce in my hair
how they see it maybe it's a good for
product I love this interview you do I
do so I think about somebody of your age
on the come up every time I got a little
more notoriety I'd be alright sweating
when I'm watching your tour diary I'm
seeing you and I'm watching you grow up
and you're sort of experiencing all
these things and it's like try not new
superpowers like when spider-man
understands that he's spider-man give me
a time when you know you as a young
international star with a big
professional team and all that that
holds used your power despite what the
people around you were saying for good I
extended leaked the ultra mainstay she's
here what does that mean can you explain
that to me it's just like the biggest
I'm trying to stay focused and Ultra is
like this big festival for a house and
electronic music and I was rehearsing
with my team in the room and on the only
photo I post on my newsroom you could
see the screen and I thought out what
the screen was already on the internet
but then this block made it like huge
news blew it up went viral and I got so
mad I wrote this loneliest comments on
his blog from my Martin garrix Facebook
post the article and you're in the
comments ya Facebook I think we've like
eight million for Facebook so if I post
something they will all see it and then
I like three people for my team saying
like no post it don't post it don't post
it they want a reaction don't do that no
I'm better don't don't do that
I accidentally hit the enter button and
it felt good not so good
it's just you want to post that yes
I said stop creating clickbait articles
the ultra stage was already on the
Internet
it was much longer a little bit more
aggressive felt amazing are you happy
you did it I'm so happy that's when I
was like living vicariously through you
and your life that's what I was thinking
about and how I would always just be
pushing buttons and testing people and
everybody would hate me and you know
that one's gonna have you can just tell
I feel good just being bad you just
gotta walk it off there's no problem
walking it off had many laps taken in
this studio edition or give me just a
second take a walk take a lap oh my god
spicy
[__] do that [__] [__] hurts it's
like it's not even in my mouth it's just
here that's what it does it takes over
the body anything it's almost running
out so I was gonna host your own milk
yeah listen this this and this over here
Martin I'm a very good host thank you
and then I looked at this and then I
totally forgot what you were saying yeah
that's how it goes it's a it's coming
from all sides here on hot ones
do you remember during the come-up walk
and red carpet or being backstage
somewhere and someone that you didn't
think know that you were you came up to
you and you're like yo are you martin
garrix I met Pharrell and fellas like my
biggest Idol he's like respect I love
yourselfers for me like I was the
happiest guy for like a week first time
I ever happened was with Chesto who was
like what was and still is my idol like
I I started making music and listening
to our music because of him and then I
have nothing one day he just followed me
on Twitter and please send me a message
like yo your [__] is dope can I release
this song of yours on my label because
he heard a demo of torrent and it was
before animals and then just to release
torrents I think in four years ago when
his label musical freedom
Barton you can always tap out that's the
thing that you can always do know so
this is the bomb
beyond insanity hot sauce it's just wash
on it
mm-hmm but listen if you listen to
caution you've made it this far in life
Martin no no this is a dreamers game
okay Rick why Bob like lots of
strategies this is so stupid I took such
a big mat enough to pilot like so many
times you are allowed to forage far
everybody's got a different strategy
never seen this one before horrible can
you talk to me about climbing come on
this is the most verbal one mm-hmm
except for these two
Wow
embrace it love it love it
[Music]
can you tell you about climbing Mulenga
and miss wing - everything went fine
until about here this one these were
these were telling was amazing thank you
I really appreciate that
don't [__] me up it's a bomb yes what
feels like a bomb
[Music]
you back with us yeah I can tell me
about climbing Kilimanjaro it was
interesting it was fun I can't even hope
for me it was fun it was I'm dying
how was the view from the top amazing
beautiful what most people view of
everything really nothing will ever be
the view the top of Kilimanjaro here
office so I'm obsessed with to our
riders because sometimes they're
outrageous and sometimes they're unique
and you can always learn a lot about the
person so I wonder what's on yours you
talked about putting the sauces I think
definitely not cross that off the list
they might when the riders for you know
what just straight up I have to step it
up yeah because that's the thing is the
other thing you can do is you can kind
of play games with venues and promoters
and stuff and just put weird items on
there and just see if they'll fill the
request you know a big move is to go
with just green M&Ms and stuff whereas
stupid that's cliche it's no there was
just someone who's gonna sort them out I
like it's not cool
well jail I would do something we did
this like a lot more like the most we
are penguin penguins
yeah that we dope does it you should do
the next time you do a Lollapalooza I'm
not doing unless you unless you put some
penguins yeah all right
everyone is loving this except except
for you I love me no one ever thinks
about me no one ever thinks about me I
have to do this this is my job you know
kind of existence that is is great job
everybody comes in here does it one time
they get these victory laps somebody a
standing ovation and Pat's on the back
nobody ever thinks about Sean over here
all right so Megadeth sauce with liquid
rage as the name would imply it is not a
very fun hot sauce it's tradition around
here to dab the last wing you don't have
to if you don't want to what so like I
kind of put like a fresh little dollop
on there I didn't mean to do anyway if
you want to pass on that move you can
it's a difference between this one and
this one a lot listen I don't want to I
feel like this one should have been here
so that's the thing everybody reacts to
these hot sauces differently so like to
me this one's worked like bad I would
agree with you these are the four worst
but I would say that our guests say in
overwhelming numbers that Mad Dog 357 is
a tougher sauce to endure than Blair's
are you're saying is to make me eat this
one no because to me you're at the point
anyway you've already gone there it
doesn't matter really how hot this sauce
is you're already already at the
intersection the car has let's do it I
love it I love it you dab it or not dab
but you don't have to dab I'm not okay
[Music]
oh brother feeling magnet it was
horrible
it's tough to escape okay cheers Cheers
all right it's all from yes so like we
talked about before when you're an
internationally famous renowned DJ they
lay out the red carpet for you it's
always the penthouse it's always the
nicest hotel room so I want while you're
dying of hot sauce for you to describe
in as much detail you can't as you can
the nicest hotel room you've ever slept
in Wow I love you so much
you listen look it's all Union thank you
Berta
all the way to the brim well this is
question nice this hotel room you've
ever been in the koozie check almost a
swimming pool like one of those were
like if you had people swimming in it
like the room underneath would see wow
people swimming in it dream hotel I
think crazy expensive though but it was
very nice if someone else pays for it
Martin
you made it through it was so amazing so
heroic you came out the other side I
think looking better than you did when
you started no I look at the number-10
Martin I look at wing number one Martin
I'm setting my friend up with wing
number ten Martin the floor is now yours
this camera or that camera tell the
world what you got going on in your life
[Music]
plug time mark guys I just released my
new single would bebe Rexha call in the
name of love I hope you'll enjoy it I
still need a lot tonight
[Music]
you